Fresh peppermint, edible blossoms: the Himmelbeet
Café specializes in vegan cuisine – and
most of the ingredients come straight from
the garden.
This is one of many urban gardening projects
in Germany.
This plot used to be a parking lot for cars.
“I'm very interested in seeing vacant areas
in the city put to good ecological use.
We want to show people where their food actually
comes from.
We also want to educate them, to show them
how this kind of gardening works, so that
they can do it themselves.”
This kind of activity brings people together.
Himmelbeet is one of Berlin's more recent
urban garden projects.
The Prinzessinnengärten, or Princess Gardens,
are now known worldwide.
In 2009 volunteers cleared this vacant lot
in the Kreuzberg district
to set up crates of plants.
These days the project serves as a model for
other urban gardens
and a popular attraction for visitors to Berlin.
“City-dwellers can try out new things here.
Without having to follow all the rules.
Cities are very regimented.
They should have open spaces where people
can work on projects like this.
Urban gardens have a real role to play – open
spaces shouldn't just be sold off.
Urban gardening should be a part of every
city.“
Vegetarian dishes are served every day in
the garden's café - and they feature ingredients
from local and regional farms.
More and more people are turning to locally-grown
and seasonal fruits and vegetables that are
produced sustainably.
Market Hall Number Nine in Kreuzberg satisfies
that demand.
Small scale farmers from around the region
sell their organically grown produce here.
It's a popular venue with locals and tourists
alike.
"We bought carrots, mushrooms, beets and sunchokes."
"Non-processed food tastes better, and I think
it's healthier, too."
And when produce is grown in or near cities,
it doesn't have to be transported over long distances.
So it's better for the environment.